are you ready to get your hands on Mass
Effect Andromeda well we finally gotten
a look at the multiplayer I'm Tony this
is a game spot news update and for even
more space game news don't forget to
subscribe the new multiplayer trailer
lays out what you can expect from
Andromeda's co-op mode you'll start off
by choosing one of over 25 characters
from either the Andromeda or milky way
galaxy from there you can jump into one
of five maps available at launch and at
the end of every match your XP and
rewards are split evenly among the team
so there's no need to hog all the kills
and that's just where the multiplayer
begins there will be over 40 weapons at
launch with more coming later the same
goes for maps which will all be free the
video also hints at additional playable
characters Mass Effect Andromeda
launches for ps4 xbox one and pc on
march 21st if you want a closer look
before launch day check out our upcoming
GS studios piece the story of Mass
Effect part one launches saturday the 18
are two launches sunday the nineteenth
and with that we'll see you in space
Pathfinder
[Music]
you